hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back welcome to let's play
and leisure custom story ah now I know I
haven't been playing a lot of amnesia
lately and there's a lot of reason for
that I kind of oversaturated it you know
in a while I mean I played the Christmas
story in that one before it but you know
I've kind of been taking it sparingly to
be honest because there's a lot more
other really cool games but I got to
remember that there's I really love him
he's so I'm back into it anyway so aisle
by Julian brøderbund I probably
butchered that name um so sorry three
years to the day passed jacob's
unspeakable horror his calamitous
repudiation and disown meant from his
own family nice words and finally his
unjust arrest and sentenced to life
imprisonment he awakes alone in his cell
beneath the depths of the Isle Morgan
Todd to an unfamiliar absence of din I
like this guy vocabulary hahaha nice
and not a single misspelling either all
right let's see what is in store for us
this is another highly rated one I mean
I've been trying to pick and choose the
best of the best I think this has an
eight point nine hello let me out of my
cell on this island I can't wake very
well yeah yeah okay hello is anybody
here
maybe someday I'll turn those hints off
but you all have to remember that I'm a
giant idiot
ergo what was that why do I keep looking
at the ceiling I'm not looking at the
scene it's automatically making me look
at the ceiling what is this hey what's
going on over here
I saw something special that I need to
know hello blue where are my captors
haha jailer Samuels due to the
decreasing stability of our current
predicament I am required to ask that
you forestall and he previously assigned
tasks and empty your jurisdiction of any
and all prisoners healthy enough to walk
escort them single file and posthaste to
the below the rest of the note is soggy
gastric and regular what okay all right
gastric irregularity this guy's
vocabulary I mean whoa Wow a sward yeah
haha oh oh this is the greatest value
ever I'm gonna go ah I'll carry that
sword with me until I die
holy hell it's a sword I'll remember
there being any sort of sword in any of
the other and these are things I seen
you all it's too cool bring it on
monsters oh you do not know the wrath of
mark plier I'll stab you hum to it I'll
stab you who'd got jeweled he'll always
lock hang on
hahaha I sure love it when they put the
key to the door right next to the door
it's used on alleviates a lot of
confusion huh did you know that they
made spiral staircases in a clockwise
manner in old keeps to prevent attackers
or to disadvantage attackers who were
normally right-handed because it's
harder to swing a right hand when it's
going in this yeah I read that recently
I on reddit probably what was that I
don't think that this is a this is a
custom custom store hey I refuse the
indignity of death by poison I would
rather be bound to lead weights at the
neck ow and cast into the Restless waves
of my dearest love the ocean below
before I allow them to drop it allowed
them a drop of Hemlock past my frail
lips counting the etchings lining the
inside of my skull reveals ten of my
years sifted away in prison in this cell
should definition itself see justice I
have died long ago hmm man I mean kayo
made this custom story is actually a
very good writer I am very surprised
usually you don't find good writing in
any of this the story has yet to be seen
if it's looking great but you know so
far very interesting
I guess the creaking gorta mór gives the
idea that I'm on a boat more than
anything
hello ha JA ok
no one's there just some rats
hey I'm a sard Oh bring it I gotta close
that door hey give me up you okay I was
so hurt you can't be me I guess I'm
supposed to climb up and I gotta bring
my sword with me top huh huh oh you'll
never find me up here
Oh with that you think you can best me
on my sword look over there oh yeah what
was that the hell wha
hang on thought oh I thought I saw
something over there that I needed
that's right back off buddy okay I need
to get over there somehow falling down
would be bad right now
there's some way I can make a bridge is
there and actually a way over there's
got to be some here oh he's gone okay
no water oh was that ha secret tinderbox
now how do I get over there how am I
supposed to get over there now maybe I
can jump nope ow ow my face give me my
sword back excelsior
ah okay so now what is this door now
unlocked or did the I guess the monster
must have bashed down a door on the
other side I will vanquish thee with my
saber of exuberant
legs you know what I mean
okay so there's oh here we go key give
me that
East Wing key I'm assuming as to that
door that was just locked over there
you like my how I hold my sword with the
blade and first I hold it by the blade
end that gives me better leverage or
something
Clegg like who it's awfully convenient
with the placement of the keys I so
apparently something happened on this
prison that was not nice miss is this
whole prison sinking into the ocean or
zone that was doing look anyway
preparations were successful I've moved
all I've moved all remaining living
prisoners out of the West Wing I left
the dead and did not check stagnant
bodies for pulses in the interest of
saving time signed the jailer so
apparently I was a stagnant corpse and I
am the zombie aha finally and a crowbar
not as handy as a sword but I guess
it'll do the lock is borked ergo it's
time to unbar kit with that crowbar hey
hot were pushed up that silly door
tricks are for kids
it's awfully dark this isn't normal
darkness it's advanced darkness all
right another locked door gotta find a
key bring it on
I don't like this place it's a little
too dark for my tastes
anything behind here carve you up know
something in this cell ah I must be good
at this game or they're laying out the
keys pretty easily for me hi none of
that I won't have none of that
now I toss my sword get the sword get
the sword
those are white rats are go ah [ __ ] you
ah my sword I wouldn't have been able to
carry it anyway I love my sword the only
thing I care about the only thing I had
in this prison and you took it away from
me I didn't ask for this I didn't ask
for this prison I didn't ask for this
walkway I didn't ask for this Lantern no
way yes I did I didn't ask for this
locked door I didn't ask for this one to
be unlocked Oh No okay alright so enough
Adam Jensen ting around is there nothing
under there didn't look like it okay
nothing's under there alright hurry whoa
ha ha
hello there's someone there meet it
demands meat well a good lot of that
around here isn't it isn't there why
water
I suppose I'm surrounded by an island so
water is hard to avoid wait what wait
what there's nothing here to see boxes
ways there's something under the water I
see a corpse there but wait what that
what that I is there something under the
water that I'm supposed to see because I
I I do not like the idea of that maybe
I'm supposed to climb up here's a leg or
an arm I can't exactly tell which ok so
uh yeah
Oh me it demands me ah that's right here
take the meat
Hey oh wait no that door was open but
this door open - hey how about that okay
that one's locked what exactly was it
that demanded meat I would like to know
oil key prison section key I have become
increasingly certain that Mont what
monstrous bellows that resonate from the
very rock are not of my imagination that
didn't mix it they induce an unshakable
horror into the tendons of every crying
prisoners voice the prison itself seems
to coil unto its own stone in fear all
right all right so I got a prison key
and apparently the prison is now afraid
of something
okay perfectly normal nothing weird
happening here that looks nice
oh wait that's where I came in that's
right that's the walkway I didn't ask
for hey why is this ground wet here wet
with blood what's with the invisible
water down there hello key prison
section key dead body pretty standard
fare
all righty then okay yeah seriously this
water's like totes mixed routes
invisible nice Keith placement again
thank you
okay the darkness is the darkness ooh ah
huh Oh oh this is nice
can't escape of course anything behind
the painting
oh is this a dream I love dreams
actually three my head wasn't do nice
you ever have a thing in your dream that
is recurring thing there's the same
house that keeps appearing in my dream
and I know it's the same house because
the layout of the house is exactly the
same each time and every time I enter
the house bad stuff happens and this has
happened multiple times in my dreams is
anyone like a good psychologist or
psychotherapist I'm not crazy
what does it mean it means that dude
you're gay what's going on what is going
on
okay all right then so uh what did that
mean
I didn't do anything well I guess I did
go to prison so I guess I did do
something know that wait the prison
Journal said that guy was innocent whoa
what the hell oh I was honest Eric what
uh well okay why can't I look that
direction what I can't all right fine I
can't even go backwards I earn lots of
quick tit what is what does that even
mean
what was that even for well what was
that what the hell is going on in this
custom story alrighty
Oh tinderbox I'm confused
Sani buddy hall jailer Samuels it
appears our hurried attention to the
aisles persistent hunger keeps it at bay
for far less a time than it once did
should our meat stock run dry at such a
time as this I want you to take full
measure to ensure our resident
abomination is kept full well in
satisfaction even if it requires a
sacrifice of personal substance sustance
substance signed the warden ok so it
means like hack off your own arm I think
is the idea there are these little gears
what do I need those for
do I need it for anything are they just
a fluff piece was this well what is this
goth away what is oh hello
I my what what oh okay
all right I'm taking this with me just
in case I need it holy crap
Oh take that what the hell was that's
the monstrosity apparently that needs to
be fed geez no thank you
I'm gonna go away now jeez I don't know
lady girl huh
okay I can't even move my mouse yes uh I
can't move is it supposed to happen or
as my just stuck I can't move I can't
move I'm gonna assume you bugged out I
can't even open my inventory yep I can't
do anything
I am totes stuck is this supposed to
happen or what I I need to know before I
get out and get back in hang on let me
save and exit and try to get back in the
game here
I wonder if this is like a sequel to
something because in there oh no I can't
I'm what the hell wah-wah I'm stuck
maybe I'm not stuck but for now I'm
gonna assume that I'm stuck
yep yeah that's it that's it I guess
that's it okay all right we're done okay
so I guess I guess that's it unless I
can somehow get to a previously those an
autosave before maybe I'll be able to
reload that or maybe that's just the end
of the game we try this one right here
because there's always a possibility
they just you know a freaky deaky bug no
that's not the right one let's try
another
I like this save right don't like this
save another no not that one geez load
game listen where you gonna put me huh
hey hey oh here
I still got my sticky doodad oh well
maybe I'm supposed to Sisseton ate this
monster or maybe I wasn't supposed to
toss in oh just a little stick doodad
okay so that's saved there ergo I should
be able to carry on and not get caught
by that douche yeah that's it
don't get caught by the douche ah you
can't get me now I'm on a bed hi
come get me ah
ah hey okay now not gonna get stuck
no I've gotta get back
ah
still can't move yep still can't move
all right I guess I guess that's it I
don't know how to I don't know how to
get around this is it did any of you
who've played this particular custom
story before know what the deal is here
because I don't understand why it would
get stuck exactly here I was actually
enjoying the story very much did I do
something wrong
is there something I need to do
differently should I just be more
persistent as I do whatever I'm doing
wrong though these are the questions
that need to be answered so for now this
is in so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
whoa-oh
good night pop good night
oh [ __ ] you wanna